there was a huge win the other night in
texas
this is texas's 34th congressional
district this is in the rio grande
valley
since 1870
democrats have held this congressional
district
1870 and then you know what happened
but we got a republican
myra flores won the special election on
tuesday night
this will be the first time the
republicans held the seat in over 150
years and by the way this will be the
first person ever born in mexico
who serves in the united states congress
and she is a republican and that is
probably going to drive the democrats
crazy because the democrats say that
we're all a bunch of white supremacists
neo nazi we hate the mexicans and then
they're looking at the polls and they
say wait why are all the mexicans
starting to vote for the republicans
why why are all the hispanics broadly
moving
pretty dramatically into the republican
camp depending on what opinion poll
you're looking at right now you are
seeing a huge shift where republicans
theoretically could win the hispanic
vote
i wish the numbers were like 80
90
for the republicans but still the the
democrats have been banking on this idea
that they can just win all the minority
votes the coalition of the ascendant and
the republican party is just going to be
the party of of old white men and
they're going to die off thankfully and
we're going to work they've got a
demographic cliff that they're falling
off of and the democrats have been
bragging about this for 20 years and now
we're seeing some chinks in that armor
now we're seeing some wait a second huh
wait the first mexican-born member of
congress is a republican it's down in a
district that the democrats held for 152
years yikes man this is probably a
pretty scary year
for the democrats
you can't even say by the way that it
was just some weird quirky election
where the democrats split the vote or
something like that flores won this is a
special election to replace an outgoing
member of congress and so
the
it's it's a kind it is a weird one in
that you had both parties running in the
same election you had multiple
candidates but you had
two republicans and two democrats
if it were one republican and two
democrats you might say well the dems
split the vote but no there's two
republicans two democrats and this lady
won and now
now she's going to take that seat and
she might be a harbinger of things to
come this could be an historic year
for the gop for the the balance of power
in congress and for hispanic voters this
might this could be the year
where hispanic voters start to really
seriously shift to the gop it has
happened to other immigrant groups this
is what happened to the italians the
italians come to america
and they
basically split up their votes
they're a little bit more conservative
in some ways i say this with some
first-hand experience of the
italian-american culture
but you've got you've got people like
scalia
right-wing republican you got people
like pelosi left-wing democrat
you got people like
michael canole over here you got people
like andrew cuomo who's a left-wing
democrat
you you can't really tell how an italian
american is going to vote just because
his last name ends in a vowel when it
comes to hispanics until very recently
you could
and there are a number of reasons for
this that have been suggested part of it
is that while the italian americans were
strongly encouraged to assimilate
sometimes at the back of a paddle they
were encouraged to assimilate
during the most recent waves of hispanic
immigration to america they were they've
actually been discouraged from
assimilating the numbers have been so
massive
migration has been so massive that there
hasn't been a lot of cultural force to
assimilate
and so politically they remain very
similar right now go to rockauto.com
enter knowles in there how did you hear
about this box so they know that we sent
you buddy mine wrote in to me the other
day he says michael i made a truly
terrible error
i went to the brick and mortar auto
parts store i know he knew what i was
going to say he goes there and this shop
tried to charge him four
hundred dollars for a party he said that
doesn't seem right what does he do he
opens up rockauto.com he goes to their
super easy to navigate website takes him
two seconds on his phone he sees they've
got the same part for 150 bucks the guy
all he came this close to overpaying by
250 bucks but what's he do he goes to
rockauto.com he gets it you don't need
to be a pro you can be a
do-it-yourselfer you don't need to go on
some special time of day
rockauto.com has every part that you
need for your car or truck it's got
reliably low prices all the time this is
a family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years don't be a
fool do not waste money and throw it out
the window go to rockauto.com get the
brakes shocks carpet wipers headlights
mirrors mufflers lug nuts or any other
part you need make sure you write nulls
in there how did you hear about his box
so they know that we sent you speaking
of good momentum for the gop and
republican politicians
speaking of billionaires throwing their
weight around in politics elon musk has
just thrown his weight around a little
bit he has suggested that he will be
backing florida governor ron desantis in
2024
so what i would say um you know i'm
focused on 2022 uh but with elon musk
what i would say is you know i welcome
support from african americans what can
i say
great answer
i assume he had that one in the back of
his head maybe it was off the cuff
really really good answer
he he did that politician thing where he
says look i'm not focused on 2024 wink
wink nudge nudge
i'm focused on 2022 i'm focused on the
state of florida even though i'm
involved in national issues every single
day and he knows he knows he's got an
incredible amount of support right now
to run for president he's by far the
best governor in america and so he's
proving himself every single day but he
doesn't want to get too out ahead of it
here don't forget it's only 20 22.
so so what does he do he makes a little
joke about it and he makes a little
politically incorrect joke too
it's not it's just a little ha ha oh
you're talking about that
african-american over there elon musk
anyway yeah that's cool i'm glad he
supports me i'm focused on florida don't
worry don't worry about it so why is he
doing this
i think this is
the smartest strategy that desantis
could be pursuing right now
ron desantis knows if he is ever going
to have a moment
this is his moment
this is it
the way he handled kovid the way he
continues to handle the economy in
florida the way that people are pouring
into florida from all around where are
they moving they're moving to texas
tennessee and florida
looking at a very weak incumbent joe
biden his own party doesn't like him an
extremely weak vice president fewer
people like the vice president somehow
than like this extremely unpopular
president
desantis is looking and saying this
could be it this could be desantis time
baby but there's one hold up here which
is
trump
trump could stop desantis from getting
the nomination very easily by the way
and he knows that
trump was a one-term president who wants
his redemption he is hinted to more than
hinted he's flat-out told people that he
is going to run in 2024 and so what can
desantis do here he doesn't want to go
head-to-head with trump
but he could miss his moment and so what
he's doing is he's getting ahead of
trump
he's starting to meet with those donors
he's starting to clearly attract some of
those big donors he's putting himself
out there in the news cycle every single
day so that if momentum builds for
desantis right now it's not building as
the anti-trump momentum
it's just building
it's just it's just it's just pro ron
it's not anti-don
so if if trump is going to run in 2024
he he's in a tough spot right now
because desantis
you see a race begin just to scoop up
money there's a limited amount of money
for
for republicans for democrats too for
anyone who's running for president
there's a limited amount of money out
there and so people have to get those
those commitments early on they've got
to get those endorsements early on
they've got to build that momentum early
on
if trump really does want to run he's
got to get ahead of desantis because
right now desantis is playing his cards
so
perfectly
it's uh it's it's hard to imagine how it
could be going any better for him and
this is still two years out but things
things move fast things move very fast
in politics politics is all about
timing
i'm so glad you like that clip now
you got to ring that bell subscribe get
the notifications right now stop
whatever you're doing stop
ring the bell subscribe now
copy the link in the url now
email it to your favorite friends and
you say you should watch this too and
subscribe greatly appreciate it we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]